hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe i'm your host sean
carroll and you're here for idea number
24
which is science uh i think that this is
not actually been guessed by anyone
people have been trying to guess you
know what other ideas are coming up
along the series i don't think anyone
guessed this one that's okay it's not
surprising
maybe someone didn't i forgot but uh
it's a bit of a departure okay this is a
meta topic the other things we've been
talking about from space
to symmetries to renormalization these
are ideas
within science mostly within physics and
now we're going to be talking about
science as a whole
this is two things i really want to get
across in this video one is going to be
how science works what science actually
is it's trickier to define
and understand than what it is it's a
whole area of intellectual thought just
to figure out what science is i'm not
going to go too deeply into it but i do
want to get some of the basics on there
because they're relevant to
how science gets done you know
scientists are not completely clueless
about what science is
they're they're often sometimes somewhat
clueless uh but they do have opinions
about it and so
what we do in science is affected by how
we think science
is going what it's supposed to be doing
and so forth the other thing i want to
talk about is
the current state and future prospects
of fundamental physics
you know even though i cheekily uh
titled this series the biggest ideas in
the universe
there's plenty of ideas we didn't talk
about that are equally big right we
didn't talk about evolutionary biology
dna we didn't even talk about various
things in condensed matter physics or
plasma physics or anything like that
we focused mostly on what i would think
of as fundamental physics
not a great name but that's what it's
called so that's what we talk about
and fundamental physics is a little bit
in a weird position
these days as many people know progress
is slower than we would like and so i'm
going to talk about that you know why
it's
low what it means what we can do about
it before we get there a couple of
administrative announcements one is
in case you don't know i wrote a blog
post
about how i make these videos in a
previous q a video
for force etc i did a little video
explanation for how i make these videos
but that's changed
and so now i've done a more elaborate
blog post you can check that out
second administrative mention is that
this is sadly the last video
in the series of the biggest ideas in
the universe it's idea number 24
in some base 12 system that's a nice
round number but i'm not even going to
be doing a q a video for this one
because it is a different kind of thing
we're not going to be talking about
substantive physics or other scientific
ideas but a little bit meta
i think that this is an appropriate
resting place this appropriate ending
note
for the series as a whole so this is the
uh last video
enormous thanks to everyone who's been
watching encouraging
so forth you know i'm very impressed
that people followed along we
went a lot deeper than i was planning to
go when i started it was also supposed
to be a quarantine project and the
quarantine is going on a lot longer than
we anticipated so the future it's hard
to predict as
wise people have said okay with those
ideas out of the way let's dive in but
even then
before i get to the two things i want to
talk about what is science
and the future of fundamental physics
let me do a little preamble
uh to get in the mood here and by the
way preamble i want to emphasize the
fact that
science oops science
is man my handwriting is
awesome now you knew that
deserves an exclamation point now you
knew that or you wouldn't be here
okay but i really not just want to say
like it's really cool doing science but
i want to drive home how incredible it
is
that physics in particular science more
generally
is as good as it is okay in
understanding the natural world
by way of a couple of examples my
favorite couple of examples about how
kind of mind-boggling it is that science
works
as well as it does so examples um
one is gravitational waves and
ligo okay we found just a couple years
ago
i should keep writing gravitational
waves uh
just a couple years ago 2016 it was
announced that the ligo and the virgo
experimental collaborations
uh detected gravitational waves um this
is something we've been looking at for a
long time
and you know you can be cynical about it
and say look we
expected them to be there all along it
would have been more surprising not to
find them but let me
let me drive home exactly how remarkable
this is okay
uh general relativity came along in
einstein
you know 1915 1916 so literally a
hundred years
before they found gravitational waves
and einstein
wrote down his field equation r mu nu
minus one half
r g mu nu equals eight pi
g t mu nu and if you don't know what
that means
we did a video on it we did the video
about gravity where we explained what
this means
not in tremendous detail but roughly
speaking the left-hand side of the
equation
is a mathematical characterization of
the curvature of space-time
and the right-hand side is a
mathematical characterization of the
sources of space-time curvature the
energy the momentum the heat and all
that stuff
okay pressure density and so forth and
so
this equation was arrived at by various
arguments you know there's more than one
way to get there we talked about the
fact that david hilbert also
derived this equation from an action
principle from the principle of least
action
whereas einstein used other arguments
about energy conservation and so forth
but they they got the same equation
and the point that i want to make is the
equation is way smarter than we are
even much smarter than einstein and
hilbert which is saying something is the
two of the
geniuses of the 20th century okay there
is stuff
hidden implicit inside this theory
that was not at all clear to the people
who invented the theory
okay so uh for one thing there's a
prediction
that there are a thing called black
holes okay
uh einstein thought that his equations
were so complicated it would be very
very difficult to find
exact solutions to them he found several
approximation schemes so he used them to
make
predictions for the orbit of mercury and
so forth
but as we mentioned soon thereafter carl
schwartshield found a solution an exact
solution
for einstein's equation with no matter
at all just empty space
uh for a spherically symmetric curvature
of
uh nature and we used that
immediately we the physicists used that
solution immediately to understand
the solar system and so forth but there
were these mathematical obstructions to
really understanding what happened when
you went
close to the center of this purported
spherically symmetric mass distribution
it took decades to figure out that what
was really going on
were these things called black holes
regions of space and time where
space-time was so curved that light
itself cannot escape
okay so it's a prediction of the theory
that was not made by the people who
invented the theory in the first place
it took a long time it was until after
einstein had died
uh the people really understood that his
theory predicted black holes it also
predicted gravitational waves
this was a little bit more readily
apparent to einstein
so einstein knew electromagnetism very
well right he knew if you took an
electron and you shake it
electromagnetic radiation
is emitted so he figured that probably
if you take a massive object and shake
it
gravitational waves would be emitted but
again the math was not
at all clear remember we had a
discussion about
gage theories and in some sense general
relativity is an example
of a gauge theory there's a symmetry
underlying what is
allowed to happen in the world and you
can interpret that as allowing for
certain kinds of things
including the curvature of space time
not other kinds of things
and this symmetry part of the symmetry
group of general relativity is just the
idea that you can change coordinates
right
you can have the same physical situation
the same curvature of space-time
but the metric which is the field that
describes what's going on in gr
can look very very different if you
change coordinates from one system to
another
so even though einstein predicted
gravitational waves he later started to
wonder
whether that prediction was correct and
you know he wondered whether or not
what he thought was a gravitational wave
solution
was really just a weird coordinate
system in flat space and in fact he he
submitted papers
arguing that there are no such thing as
a gravitational wave so he was wrong
about that but
eventually and you know different people
wasn't just einstein many people argued
back and forth
eventually we realized yes gravitational
waves are actually real
okay so this set of predictions
was there in the theory this is part of
my point that you know physics is
smarter than physicists
are the theory knew perfectly well that
there could be gravitational waves in
black holes but it did
you know the scientists took decades to
figure that out and once they did
you know they they invented the ligo
project the laser interferometric
gravitational wave observatory uh
the first sort of glimmers of an idea
were in the 1970s
uh for interferometric gravitational
wave detectors
in the 1980s some steam began to build
up in the 1990s we started spending real
money
on this kind of project and uh it in the
end of the day it cost about a billion
dollars
in american money to make we don't need
a plural there
uh to build the ligo experiment
and a lot of people were still skeptical
that it would find anything they believe
in gravitational waves
but gravity gravity is very very weak
okay and gravitational waves are
very very tiny perturbations on any
experimental apparatus you can build
i mean the idea behind ligo is that you
have
two vacuum tubes that are perpendicular
to each other
and there is a beam splitter and so you
send a laser
and part of it goes this way part of it
goes that way and there are mirrors and
then they bounce off
the lasers bounce off and come back to
you and if there's a misalignment
in the wavelength of the lasers caused
by
the mirrors moving then you detected
something
okay now maybe what you detected is a
truck rolling by just vibrating the
floor
of the gravitational wave observatory
but maybe what you've detected
is a gravitational wave coming in and
moving the mirrors
and so the challenge was to make sure
that you didn't that you were able to
pick out the actual signal
above the noise and a lot of people were
skeptical that that would ever happen
just to drive this home
the amount by which the mirrors move the
actual physical distance
that the mirrors move in the
gravitational wave detection that was
announced in 2016
is less than the size of a proton okay
it is a very very very short distance
and you're saying yourself well
how in the world can you detect like
there's a big mirror that's made of many
many protons
well the answer is that you bounce many
photons off the mirror
and they remain collimate it's a laser
right okay they're they're
in lockstep and you build up a lot of
statistics and you look for the tiny
tiny deviation
over and above the known noise sources
not easy to do
took decades to build etc billion
dollars
and what they found what they announced
was that there were
two black holes
each of them was about 30 times the mass
of the sun
and they were about 1 billion light
years away
these two black holes had spiraled into
each other and they gave off
gravitational waves and there was a
signal that lasted for
seconds that was detectable by this
observatory okay
this was a prediction that was secretly
embedded
in this theory when einstein and hilbert
for that matter wrote it down
uh but they had no idea it was there
later people worked it out they spent a
billion dollars and decades and a lot of
smart people's
lives looking for it and they found it
and it was exactly what the theory
predicted there were no
detected deviations so when einstein
came up with general relativity it
wasn't like you know
okay this is a step and then we'll take
you know it'll improve it along
the way sometimes science is like that
you know darwinian evolution
is like that um biology is much messier
than physics is but
nature has this pristine
structure somewhere embedded in it okay
number one there is that structure in
there and number two we can find it
we human beings at least a little bit
you know at least provisionally in some
sort of haphazard way
we can discover some of what structure
is there in nature
and that's pretty amazing to me uh it'll
never stop being amazing
another example along exactly the same
lines
is the higgs boson okay
so in 1964
peter higgs and also a bunch of other
people especially uh robert brow
and francois anglair were thinking about
not the mass of the electron or anything
like that they were thinking about the
question of
why the nuclear forces were short range
okay we knew that gravity and
electromagnetism were long-range forces
um we knew experimentally that there
were short-range forces in the atomic
nucleus
what is going on there okay and we
discussed this
in the in the um various biggest ideas
videos about symmetries
and gauge theories and so forth if you
fill space with this field that has a
non-zero expectation value
you can sort of cut off the lines of
force that would want to extend out
to infinity higgs and brow and anglair
were all thinking that what they were
explaining was the strong nuclear force
what we now know thanks to steven
weinberg and others is that what they
were really explaining was the weak
nuclear force
and the funny thing was um brown angler
actually wrote
the first paper on this and higgs wrote
a paper about it and then
higgs wrote a follow-up paper that was
rejected by the journal it's like you
know why
this is too speculative okay back in the
60s the standards for being speculative
were a lot higher than they are now
um so higgs you know thought about it
and he actually just shifted to
submit to another journal which is a
very standard procedure in
academia but he said you know i really
he thought to himself i should beef up
my paper i should put something in there
that uh
is more you know irresistible to the
referees and so he realized that he
could
use this theory to predict the existence
of a new particle the higgs boson
okay so brown angler didn't mention the
prediction of a new
particle higgs only mentioned it because
he was trying to beef up his paper after
it was rejected okay so
it's perfectly fair to give brown angler
uh the id
the credit for the original idea but it
was higgs who discover who predicted the
boson the actual particle
and again they were predicting it for a
different reason
in some sense than we currently use it
for they were thinking about the strong
nuclear force not the weak nuclear force
and for that matter the 1960s was a time
when quantum field theory was
in decline you know we think about the
origins of quantum field theory in the
1930s
and there were puzzles and neil feynman
and schwinger and dominaga and others
did renormalization it was all very
triumphant and today of course we have
the standard model and it's super duper
triumphant
but it wasn't a monotonic increase in
the
triumph of quantum field theory the 60s
were a low point where
there was a proliferation of particles
that we couldn't explain
there were mathematical problems with
quantum field theory that did not get
fixed by feynmanesque uh diagrams and
renormalization techniques etc
so people were trying to do things like
called there's something called
s matrix theory that they were trying so
the fact that these folks were using
quantum field theory
and they were motivated by you know
somewhat abstruse considerations and
they made this prediction
okay that there's going to be this
particle
and 48 years later
the large hadron collider took about 10
billion dollars
they found the higgs boson and you
really should give credit here to
stephen weinberg who in 1967
proposed a model using this mechanism to
explain the masses uh and couplings of
leptons electrons and and the muon etc
but you know it was again spot on
it was exactly what they predicted and
you know it barely got in there
on time for most of the original
discovers uh robert brown sadly passed
away
before they discovered it but the but
higgs and anglair and the others who
discovered it were still around
and um unlike gravitational waves which
had not been discovered when it's uh
which had not which took a lot longer to
discover but again the point being that
they were able to just use their brains
and what we knew about particle physics
to make this prediction decades ahead of
time
and we did this the most complicated
experiment ever done
and we found they were exactly right in
some sense why
because there is something true and real
and rigid
about nature that science can uncover
that's what i mean when i say that
science is awesome
many of you will be thinking of uh the
famous paper by eugene wigner
called the unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematical of mathematics in physics
you know
and the example he gives is you know a
friend of his was
doing some statistics and was using a
gaussian normal distribution remember
the normal distribution
and when you we didn't actually
normalize the normal distribution we
didn't integrate it and set it equal to
one but when you do
the pre-factor involves pi and some
friend of the friend
said like that's ridiculous pi is the
ratio over circumference to the diameter
of a circle that has nothing to do with
the statistics problem you're doing
how does pi come in there and wigner's
point is mathematics just suffuses all
through
the structure of physics in in
remarkable ways
and you know i'm not quite sure that
it's as remarkable as vigner made it out
to be like if the laws of physics were
different
i think we would still describe them
mathematically even if what happened
from moment to moment in the universe
was completely random
there would still be some distribution
of what happened and we use statistics
to describe it so
the thing that is remarkable to me is
not the effectiveness of mathematics
but the simplicity and rigidity the
unforgiving nature
of the underlying laws that seem to be
obeyed
by nature and again it's not just
physics i pick physics because it's a
very wonderful
set of examples very close to my heart
old school physics also very good you
know
isaac newton's inverse square law of
gravity is still what we use to get
around the solar system if you're
nasa and uh in biology and so forth
those of you who are listeners to my
podcast
uh just released a podcast with theodore
ornov who works on
gene editing with crispr okay the idea
that we can borrow
techniques from bacteria to go in there
and edit the human genome
right this is kind of amazing stuff you
know science science is pretty awesome
that's what i'm that's what i'm getting
at here
and the sense in which it's awesome it's
it's two things it's not just that it's
true things you know as one
i was once asked by an economist um
who's little peeved because
the point was how come physicists
are so admired intellectually and
economists are not that was
that was the question so i'm not quite
sure the premise of the question
is exactly true economists appear on tv
a lot more than physicists do for you
know public policy recommendations and
probably that's
the correct thing but i got the point
and so the answer i tried to give was
physics not only describes and discovers
true things about the world but they are
number one
demonstrably true you can test them you
know they get unambiguously
signals in the detector whether it's a
large hadron collider or ligo or
whatever
and number two they're surprising
results
the idea that there are black holes and
the idea that there is a higgs boson
and you know there's this field
pervading space that cuts off the weak
nuclear force
you wouldn't have guessed these things
just sitting around the campfire right
you know just using your brain power
um physics is able to discover things
about the world that are both true
and surprising and uh you know economics
finds out things that are true
uh whether or not they're simultaneously
true and surprising
and explicable to the wider world is a
harder thing right
the number of surprising things i think
i can say this with confidence the
number of
surprising things that physics has
discovered and has demonstrated are
true is larger and more impressive than
that which economics has discovered
this is absolutely no knock on
economists economics is much harder
right
we started this set of videos with a
spherical cow philosophy the idea that
we can simplify the world
and still make progress in physics
that's why physics is
great that's why physics is so is so
possible
to make so much progress because physics
is easy right the world is a simple
place
okay thus that is my preamble spiel on
why science is awesome let's think about
what science is and you know
i'm not uh completely clueless here
what i'm going to say about science uh
will is a little bit less
rah-rah than many people often are i'm
gonna you know i'm gonna admit
that science is complicated okay um
which i wanted to first get off
you know get on the table the fact that
science is awesome we should all agree
on that but what science is
is much more complicated than what a lot
of people say so
i'm going to try to make two points and
in the next few minutes when i'm talking
about this
there'll be a continual sort of give and
take i'm going to say a
but also a little bit of not a right so
this is this is a field once you get
into sort of the philosophy or history
or sociology of science
where there are very few absolutes to
say like you have to find your way
in between a spectrum of different
possibilities okay
so what i want to say about science is
on the one thing on the one hand it is
something
in other words uh
there are things that are not science
right there are activities you can do
that are perfectly respectable
activities and some disreputable ones
that are not science there's a
difference between being science and not
being science okay that is clear
but on the other hand it is hard to pin
down what exactly counts
as science and doesn't and in fact it is
so hard to pin down
that the problem of pinning down what is
science and what is not science
is a famous problem that has a name the
demarcation problem
demarcating here is science here is not
science and a lot of people get it very
very wrong
and i'm not going to try to give you the
once and for all final answer i have
enormous respect for the people who are
doing the hard work in philosophy and
history and sociology of science
to point out all of the ways in which
science is a little bit messier
than what you thought so i'm going to
sort of lean into that messiness i'm
going to
talk about some of the aspects of
science but not pretend to have the once
and for all
final explication of what it actually is
so what is it what is going on when we
do science um
here's the way that i think about it we
observe the world
okay so we look at it that is one aspect
of doing science we collect data we do
experiments we look in our telescopes
and our microscopes whatever
we figure stuff out about the world even
before we called it science we just look
around and go huh there's a table right
there's a chair things like that there's
the sky
there's rain falling from the sky we
thought about it okay
as soon as you start thinking about it
you try to make sense you try to develop
a model
in your mind like okay it rained
yesterday will it rain today right what
are the chances
can i predict ah you know like the sky
is red does that mean it's going to rain
you try to find patterns and
regularities and develop a
theory for what's happening in the world
so that's another aspect
so you theorize you sort of develop some
kind of
formal or informal system uh some sort
of structure that says if this then that
these two things are correlated these
two things are related this is the
correct vocabulary to talk about the
natural world
and so forth and clearly there's a give
and take
you theorize on the basis of what you
have seen and you
uh your theories suggest to you
what you can look at right or what you
should look at because you want to test
your theories
in fact i'm going to separately put down
a little blob for
compare by which i mean comparing
theories
with the observations because
comparing theories with observations is
not trivial it's not just automatic it
doesn't just happen
okay there's a lot of work going into
saying what theories predict
and going from the observations to a
theoretical implication of them okay i
mean
this is way more obvious now than it
used to be because these days we have
computer simulations right
um people will simulate the formation of
a galaxy or the explosion of a supernova
or something like that and there are
they debate sometimes if i'm a person
who writes
a code to simulate a supernova explosion
am i a theoretical
astrophysicist or am i a computationally
experimental
astrophysicist am i creating new data
the answer is you're not an experimenter
you're using your computer to compare
theory to data
this this compare or analyze sometimes
we call this
analysis or something like that uh
analyze oops i'm not in england analyze
analyze the data compare it with the
theory okay that's a a
part of science all by itself and all
these different aspects kind of work
together and talk to each other in
complicated ways
some of you like me may have been
subjected to the baconian scientific
method when you were in high school okay
francis bacon
uh back in the day uh it's actually the
history of the stuff is fascinating if
you want to read about it because
the bocconi and scientific method is
this idea that you
invent hypotheses you've got to collect
data you test your hypothesis you come
back and you know is it is it correct or
is it is it false right
so this didn't really arise organically
and i'm not an expert in
uh the history of this but my
understanding is literally
francis bacon and his friends sat around
and said we have to invent something
called the scientific method
because we need to sort of gain some
respectability for this new activity
that we're all i don't know if they call
it the scientific method but
they wanted to they were very explicit
about the need to sort of
become more respectable and so they
promulgated this idea of a scientific
method
it's entirely nonsense that sort of high
school level scientific method
there is no beginning or end to this
process right you don't know what comes
first maybe your theory came first maybe
your observations came first i mean
in some sense your observation some
observations came first before you had
the idea to invent theories of them
but it's a constant give and take and
you constantly change your theories in
response to the observations
and you choose what observations to make
in response to the theories and so forth
it's nothing
clean and cut and dried like bacon would
have said
and in fact i want to i want to mention
something else here
which is all this stuff is done
by human beings right by people and
if we really care about what happens in
the progress of science like
where in here did i mention applying for
grants
where in here that i mentioned teaching
phd students
or you know building a laboratory or
grading people or hiring people or
firing people
or giving people prizes or citing people
or getting published right writing
papers
or not citing people or giving seminars
i didn't mention any of those things
but those things are crucially important
to the progress of science to the
practice of science
so let's make another uh bubble here in
a slightly different color for what i'll
call
socialize not socializing in the sense
of uh sitting around having drinks but
the human side of all of these things
right the
actual interactions between people and
this is important for
all of these different aspects okay
whether you're
i mean it's clearly important for
theorists they need to talk to each
other they need to understand what the
data is talk to the
experimenters for experimenters who need
money for their
experiments the socializing is even more
important and likewise for the
analysts so just to emphasize i'm not
going to talk about that aspect in great
detail
but just to emphasize that i do want to
get across the sort of truism
that science is a human activity okay so
let's
let's note this is this is it this is my
answer to what science is the science is
the set of activities all in interaction
with each other in an attempt to better
understand what's happening in the
natural world that is what science is
and i want to note two things okay
let me change back to white two things
one thing is that whatever science is it
is not
revelation
revelation or pure logic
that is to say this is sort of the
single most important thing that
differentiates
science from other ways that you might
try to understand the fundamental nature
of reality
you might say well maybe god tells me
the fundamental nature of reality right
maybe it's just revealed
to me that's what revelation means so
revelation is often
uh associated with a literally religious
point of view theism or something like
that but
let's just take it in a broader meaning
to say like
somehow true information about the
nature of reality
appears in my mind in some way other
than me going out and looking at it okay
that's what science denies science says
you know
i can come up with ideas about the
universe i can
invent ideas and say maybe things are
like this
but in order to know whether or not
those ideas are true
i have to look at the universe okay
that's the crucial thing science is
about recognizing
that things could have been different
there is relativity but there's also
classical newtonian mechanics these are
different the universe is expanding but
it could have been contracting
in the sense that uh we mentioned before
david lewis
who is very famous the philosopher very
famous for this
taking seriously the idea of the set of
all possible worlds okay
in some sense you can think of the
activity of science as saying
here all the possible worlds let's find
which one is our actual world that's
what science is trying to do and you
can't do it
a priori so it's different than logic or
mathematics right like you can prove
logically or mathematically that from
certain assumptions
certain conclusions flow right from the
axioms of number theory two plus two
equals four
from different axioms different things
would flow we know this we we
encountered this in geometry right from
euclidean
axioms the postulates of euclid you can
derive certain theorems like parallel
lines always remain exactly parallel
but you could imagine different axioms
right
under which parallel lines diverge or
converge or do weird things
and science says
you can go ahead and develop these
mathematical theorems based on
postulates
but you're not going to know which
postulates are applicable to the real
world
unless you go out and look at it right
so it is a fundamentally
empirical kind of thing and let me sort
of drive this home a little bit
um in a couple of more specific ways it
is empirical
so i actually put very explicitly
revelation and logic
as two different things because i don't
want to denigrate either one you know
like
maybe there is revelation uh there
certainly is logic but neither one of
them is science okay science is
specifically about
letting various possibilities be true
not knowing them a priori and going out
and looking
at the world that's what it means to be
empirical
recognizing that things could have been
otherwise another aspect of this
is that it is provisional
so the thing about math
or logic is that you can prove things
and if you didn't make a mistake in your
proof which sometimes happens but if you
like
want to prove that the square root of 2
is an irrational number
you can do that and then you know with
metaphysical certainty
it's 100 true you know that square root
of 2 is an irrational number because you
have a proof of it
in science there are never proofs that a
certain theory
is absolutely 100 correct it is
necessarily provisional because
there could always be an experiment
tomorrow that is in conflict
with your theory no matter how good your
theory is
so there are no proofs in science
science
does not prove things and so this is
this is a thing where scientists get in
trouble because they know this right
even if they don't ever uh
say it explicitly they know that science
doesn't prove things
so if you want to be anti-science and
you want to sort of get a scientist to
stumble
in public conversation you say well have
you proven that this is true and the
scientists will say no
because they know that they've never
proven anything is true uh they've
demonstrated that it's extremely likely
that something is true but it's never
quite the level of a proof that you get
in math or logic
and finally it's ground up not like
ground up into pieces
but science happens from the ground up
is what i mean by this
in other words just like there are no
proofs there are no popes
there's no no pope of science who just
hands down the rules there's no emperor
no king no queen
okay there's no academy that decides
okay here's the truth and here is not
the truth okay
you know i i sometimes compare and
contrast science in democracy
democracy and science are different okay
they're trying to do different things
people are very
very very insistent that science is not
a democracy
and that is true you do not find the
truth by voting
but there is a crucially important
similarity between them
in that both bubble up from the bottom
rather than being imposed from the top
the idea of democracy is that rather
than an autocrat
who makes the decisions once and for all
and the people obey
the people ultimately through one way or
the other one mechanism or the other
have the authority to make decisions in
your state okay
likewise this is the similarity between
science and democracy
likewise science does not proceed by the
smartest person in the room saying
here's what's true now you all listen to
me
okay anyone can show that previous
scientific beliefs were wrong
so the cheeky way of putting it is if
you're a theologian
and you write a paper that shows the
pope made a mistake you get
excommunicated from the catholic church
if you're a physicist who writes a paper
that says that einstein was wrong in
some important way
you win the nobel prize science is not
about uh
bucking up the establishment and saying
why it is correct
uh now that's unfair to religion and to
other aspects of life
or even dictatorships because you can
still have progress and change
in those situations in those systems but
science is built for progress and change
it's
what it's all about the excitement of
science
is showing that the accepted wisdom is
wrong somehow
now again you have to temper that as i
said at the beginning of this i'm going
to say
this but also that the excitement comes
from showing the accepted wisdom is
wrong
but usually the accepted wisdom is right
right it's a rare wonderful event where
you can truly show the accepted wisdom
is wrong
so you have to like take into account
that you want to show
the accepted wisdom is wrong and
therefore that's a temptation to sort of
lean into that a little bit too much
and you have to say well how do i know
you have to be very very careful you
have to really
understand the temptations to overthrow
the system it's hard to overthrow the
system in a paradigmatic science anyway
okay um the other thing that was one
thing i wanted to say the other thing
is that every component of this little
story
observing the world theorizing about it
comparing those two
and all the different social aspects of
science every component is messy
so the the way to say this i think
is that science just by
its product right by what you get out of
science you can do technology you can
understand the world you can predict the
existence of gravitational waves and so
forth okay
um it gives the impression
of being pristine and algorithmic and
objective
okay uh and it's not it's really not it
tries to be
as objective as it possibly can be but
every single one of these aspects of
science is a mess and is a human
activity that cannot be reduced to an
algorithm
so let me just mention you could go on
for days you could write phd theses on
all the different ways
in which science is kind of messy let me
just mention some of them
so in other words what i'm getting at
here is given this kind of structure
what people will try to do
is reduce the activity of science to an
algorithm that's what bacon and his
friends were trying to do
it is doomed to fail that process it's
not supposed to be reducible
to an algorithm there's not an algorithm
for figuring out how to make progress in
science
so you might say well look i observe the
world i come up with a theory
and my theory makes a prediction i make
a prediction and i go out and test the
prediction by making some observation
to figure out whether my theory is true
or not right that's what you might say
if you were being a little bit naive and
simple-minded about how science works
but in the real world here's some things
you have to take into account
what do you observe we say okay you go
out and look at the world you make some
observations well
what observations there are literally an
infinite number of potential things you
could observe about the world right
when the large hadron collider uh
reported its data
that said that the higgs boson had been
discovered they did not tell you what
the humidity was in the room they did
not tell you who had won the local
football match that day right they did
not tell you what color
of socks the physicists were wearing
there's an enormous amount of
information that is
left out when you do observations there
are
reasons why it's left out some
information some data are relevant to
the question of what theories are true
and some
are not we think but that's a judgment
that the scientists make right the very
and
nowhere is it more clear than in this
exam these examples of the large hadron
collider and ligo
billions of dollars are being spent why
because we trusted that there were
predictions being made
by scientists that this precise really
really difficult observation
was worth it okay there's a process of
deciding what observations are worth
making
you can put it crudely in terms of how
to spend the money you know in some
science budget but even if you had
an infinite amount of money you don't
have a amount of time
some observations would be more useful
than others and that's a that's a
human judgment in some sense um
are the observations correct
so some of you might remember a few
years ago
when there was a press conference at
cern home of large hadron collider but
before the higgs boson
that said that they discovered that
neutrinos move faster than the speed of
light
okay it was later shown to be wrong
there was a wire that was loose
literally um but look if that had been
true
it would have been the most important
scientific discovery of many many many
decades
um and yet scientists physicists did not
get all that excited about it
why because observations are sometimes
wrong
and this observation was so in conflict
with our theoretical expectation
that no one believed it everyone said
that even without knowing even without
being an expert
in the experimental techniques everyone
who was an expert in physics and yeah
yeah
it doesn't seem very likely i'm gonna
wait for that one to go away right
and you could be wrong about that maybe
they'd they would do it again and other
people would verify it and you would
then eventually have to change your mind
but in fact they were right to say that
the experiment was wrong it was wrong
so just because there is an experiment
that says the theory is in trouble
doesn't mean you declare victory you
have to
again have some judgment about what
experiments to take seriously and which
ones to
discard um
how to theorize so this is this is
always the big
mystery about the bocconi and scientific
method and actually i first learned
about this issue or is impressed upon me
by reading
of all things uh robert robert pierce
book
zen and the art of motorcycle
maintenance uh incendiary motorcycle
maintenance he makes a big deal
of the fact that there's this step in
the high school scientific method that
says
come up with a hypothesis and then test
that hypothesis and he's like
what do you mean come up with a
hypothesis how do you do that
what is it that what is the process you
go through to invent a hypothesis
it seems you know at the level we
currently understand it all you can do
is say things like it's fundamentally a
creative
thing right you need to be a smart
physicist that has some
spark of ingenuity to be able to say oh
let's think of it in this new clever way
einstein like we can tell ourselves
stories
about einstein's amazing physical
intuition and his ability to invent
thought experiments with elevators and
rocket ships and trains and so forth
but a little bit of that is x-pos facto
you know like he did it so we tell a
story about how it happened
we don't know how to invent good
scientific theories we just hope it
happens and encourage people to do it
it's not something that we can turn into
an algorithm
what do the theories predict okay
so we say okay you get a theory
you make a prediction you test it
against the data right
the real world and again we're saying
that every component here is messy
in the real world maybe your theory
isn't done yet
or maybe you just don't know what your
theory predicts
so again einstein just used examples
that are familiar from our previous
videos
einstein wrote down his theory of
relativity he said what if the universe
is
homogeneously filled with matter or
radiation
and he realized oh my goodness i predict
that it will either be expanding or
contracting
then he talked to his friends the
observers and they said it's not
expanding or contracting because
observations are not always correct
right or at least they can be incomplete
so did he
just say oh i guess general relativity
is wrong i guess my theory has been
falsified by the data
no of course he did not say that he said
hmm i wonder if i could change my theory
a little bit so he added the
cosmological constant
this was not cheating this was not
fudging
we now know the cosmological constant is
actually there at least we think it is
with high
probability it wasn't a wrong thought
that einstein had it just wasn't the
right answer to that particular issue
because the observations were misleading
in that particular
case but the this should be
in principle the simplest part of
science like you have a theory make a
prediction
right but turning that into you know
knowing exactly what your theory
predicts often requires a bit of
judgment
also um and then
finally of the many many things we could
say
vague ideas
often precede theories
so einstein was lucky
in the sense that when he invented
general relativity well he wasn't lucky
he was einstein he's very smart
so he mentioned relativity it was a very
very precise rigorous theory but
you know he had the idea that space-time
was curved
years before he had the field equations
for general relativity he made
predictions for things like
the gravitational redshift and things
like that long before he had the full
theory much more common is you have kind
of a notion
that that you should be moving in a
certain direction theoretically
long before you have the full theory
like we talked in these in these videos
about quantum mechanics
and the foundations of quantum mechanics
many worlds and bohmian mechanics and
spontaneous collapse theories none of
these
theories are 100 finished yet okay the
closest is many worlds
it's just objectively true that many
worlds at least has a clear statement of
what the theory is
but there's still a lot of work to be
done connecting that theory to
predictions for
experiments the theory is not fully
developed yet and the other theories you
know pilot wave theories or spontaneous
collapse theories are not
completely compatible with quantum field
theory or quantum gravity or anything
like that which is not to say they won't
be
maybe they need to be developed into
theories that are completely compatible
so in the real world
when you say okay i have a theory make a
prediction your theory just might not be
up to the task
if you want to write in your face
important example here
many many modern astrophysicists think
that the universe began or
close to began with an inflation period
of super accelerated expansion that
explains the perturbation that they grow
into galaxies and so forth
but inflation is an idea it's not a
certain specific theory so if you say
well okay using inflation
predict the exact level of anisotropy in
the cosmic microwave background
it can't inflation is a family of many
different kinds of theories alan guth
himself who invented it
likes to call it the inflationary
paradigm rather than inflationary
theory it's sort of a set of many
theories so even if you have
something that is a good idea that might
be true it might not yet be a theory and
so all of this is just to say
that all these components in the real
world
not in fake make-believe pristine
algorithmic world in the real world
these are a mess
okay and that is not a bug
it's a feature it's how science works
um it's not that there's nothing
objective okay what's objective is
nature
reality is there you know there's
something there
that is uh objective and unchanging and
independent of human thought when it
comes to what
nature is at least that's the
precondition
of doing science that there is some
objective reality out there that we are
learning about
but the process of learning about it is
not objective so
science is a non-objective technique
for learning non-certain
features of the objective certain
reality
underneath us all all that is true at
the same time and you shouldn't be
ashamed of it it's not it's not that you
know we're not good at science yet and
someday it will turn into an algorithm
it need not be an algorithm it's a
fundamentally human pursuit
of developing the best theories that we
have of nature
so even though it's a mess it really
does capture some truth and i want to
say
you know there's again here's another
continuum
there's a set of people who don't know
that much about science but love it and
think that science just gives you the
truth
right like if you just do science then
you will get the truth there's another
people who also love
science but many of these people are
working scientists and they
prefer to emphasize the fact that
you can't prove things in science right
that was a
one of the things we said no proofs
right so they will say
that the fundamental lesson of science
is that you never know for sure
anything okay anything could be
overthrown
and you know again strictly speaking
sure you never know anything for sure
but the most useful place to live is in
between
those two extremes where you think that
science is just facts and
immutable truths and when you think that
science is just the statement that we
never know anything okay
we do know some things science does
teach us some things but the things it
teaches us are necessarily approximate
and provisional um you know gravity
pulls things together here on earth
right if you if you jump out the window
with very high confidence you will fall
down you will not fall up under the
force of gravity
you can't know for sure but it is
something that is worth taking very
seriously so
i don't know exactly what words to
attach to this but you know in a legal
context we would say that some things
are established beyond reasonable doubt
and science never establishes anything
beyond metaphysical doubt right it never
says that anything is
a hundred percent certain but certain
things can be
99.9999 certain right and then you go
like i don't want to waste my time
thinking about these other possibilities
that is also very possible
so not only do we actually learn things
but we we learn them
to the point where it is not worth
paying attention to alternatives that's
a very very high standard i don't
wouldn't want to leap there too quickly
there are certainly cases in the history
of science where people have left there
too quickly
thought they were more certain than they
should be but nevertheless
we can eventually get there so science
does teach us something even if it's not
perfect it's tricky okay that's that's
the point it's not like
cut and dried and that is one of the one
of the things that people fail at is
they try to turn science into something
a bit more cut and dry
than it really is so just to drive this
home i want to drive home this message
even
even further uh by comparing different
ways of logically reaching conclusions
okay different uh logical techniques
there's the technique
called deduction
abduction there we go deduction is you
know
something that you can put in the form
of a syllogism for example right you're
all familiar with this right
uh a implies b a
is true therefore
b um socrates is a man
all men are mortal therefore socrates is
mortal right that's
very nice and logical and uh this is a
perfectly good
form of logical argument and it's it's
very admirable because
if you're sure that a implies b
and you're sure that a is true then you
can
safely say that b is true you've proven
it to be true
the problem is that science is never
sure about either of the premises of the
argument so these are the premises and
this is the conclusion
okay so in science you're never going to
be sure about the conclusion of a
deductive argument because you're never
sure where the premise is
you could always be wrong about some of
the premises so deduction although it's
it's seductive as a way of learning true
things it is not the way that science
works
and this is pretty clear people sort of
knew this for a long time
so there was this idea that maybe we
should think about science in terms of
induction
okay a different method logical method
of learning new true things
and the very very short version of
induction let me see how i wrote it down
here
let's imagine we have a sequence of
statements a sub
n a1 a2 a3 etc right so if you
if you know that if a n is true
then a n plus one the next statement in
the list
is necessarily true if a n then a n plus
one a
n implies a n plus one
if you know that and you know a1
is true okay so you have some starting
point then
therefore all a n are true for all
n okay then you've proven a whole list
of things right
so um uh if
n is even then n plus two is even
two is even therefore four is even six
is even eight is even et cetera you can
prove inductively that all those numbers
are even numbers
there's probably better examples of
inductive proofs but this is also
a absolutely valid way of doing logic
and proving things from the premises
you see the problem which is that in the
real world in
in science we never know if these
premises are true
and it was david hume our old buddy
david hume
who pointed this out he says yeah you
know i see why you think that science
works this way you see something
happening you see it again and you see
it again
uh you know you see the pen fall you see
it fall again
you see it fall again and you're like i
bet next time it's going to fall oh i
was right
okay that's kind of like induction right
like you're collecting a lot of data
you see that a series of things are true
and then you say okay it's going to
continue to be true
but hume points out it could change
tomorrow
right you don't know with metaphysical
certainty that just because the pen
fell every time it will also fall
tomorrow and indeed
there are possible worlds i could invent
laws of physics where the pen falls
every day except tomorrow it falls up
right or it push flies up i guess so
this is hume's
problem of induction you can never be
sure in the real world so you need to
separate out
mathematical or logical induction which
is very valid
from sort of the attempt to make
induction empirical or scientific where
it fails okay
induction is not the way that science
works
so there's another way that it's worth
thinking about that is much much closer
to the real world and this is called
abduction
it's kind of like kidnapping somebody
but not exactly and this is associated
with charles sanders purse
his name is spelled kind of like pierce
but it's pronounced purse
uh if you're not already a huge fan of
cs purse i recommend looking online or
buying a book and reading about him he
was
a polymath a philosopher a linguist a
mathematician an inventor
um he was a weird guy he lived you know
about
a little over a hundred years ago so uh
end of the
19th centuries when he really flourished
bertrand russell said he was the
greatest american intellect of all time
there have been other american elects
since then but
he was a founder of pragmatism as a
school of philosophy
made major contributions to semiotics he
was a cartographer he invented new
projections of the globe and things like
that
okay and but he was also slightly crazy
and hard to get along with
um he spent the last couple decades of
his life in poverty
and after he died it was discovered he
left behind over a hundred thousand
pages
of unpublished manuscripts about
everything in the world
which most of them are still unpublished
we don't even know but anyway
so purse is looking is worth looking
into he's enjoying a bit of a
renaissance uh
lately so the idea behind abduction
is the idea that rather than being
purely a hundred percent
logical and proving things what we do is
we try to infer what is the best
explanation
for something in fact there's there's a
debate in philosophy circles there's
something called
inference to the best explanation which
is very very similar to abduction but
people
wonder whether or not it's the same or
not so i don't care i'm not i'm not
drawing those fine distinctions but
the basic idea is that rather than these
sort of premises and conclusions kind of
thing
you have a large set of data and i'm
putting this in my own words i'm not
sure if purse would have recognized this
so you have a set of data a1 a2
a3 so data or you know observations
things you think are true about the
world facts
in some sense or another by the way
interestingly you know i called these
data and i said you could call them
facts
do you know that scientists almost never
use the word facts i actually checked
this because
you know back in the day where we're
debating creationism um you know
science and facts was a big deal and so
uh
i i thought about it in my my daily
routine as a scientist
no one ever talks about facts even
though those are associated with science
what they talk about are data and the
reason why is because
you don't know what the facts are you
know what the data are but like we said
observations can be wrong so i literally
like went through
um titles in the particle physics
archive and looked for the appearance of
the word facts and like they were almost
never there
there's like two papers then you look
for words like data or evidence there's
huge
piles of things okay so deep in their
bones no matter how much they talk when
they try to play philosophers
scientists know how provisional what
they do is and
they are actually a little bit careful
about understanding that what they have
to deal with are data
and some of those data could be wrong
it's a mistake to promote
a datum to a fact without putting little
footnotes saying well unless we're wrong
about this
so let's call this data a set of data
and then what you have are a set of
hypotheses about the data
b1 b2 b3 you know maybe
the universe is expanding versus
contracting dark matter is axions the
dark matter are wimps dark matter or
black holes whatever it is set of
hypotheses
then you ask yourself which
bi best
explains
all those data all the a n
and you say that bi is probably true if
it's the one that best explains all the
data okay
now you might be outraged by this you're
like this is not the same
as deduction or induction because and
you're right deduction and induction
give you 100
true results if you start from 100 true
premises okay
whereas this seems very fuzzy like what
do you mean
best well what counts is the best
explanation
uh is it the simplest explanation is the
one with you know you can state is it
sort of the smallest common role of
complexity
uh does it is it you know the the
easiest to explain to other people does
it make the most predictions like what
do you mean by the best explanation
yeah that's a good question that is hard
to answer
um you know thomas kuhn a later
philosopher of science
he wrote the structure of scientific
revolutions and he got accused
by a lot of people for being a
relativist about science because of
things he said in structure about how
if you believe in one theory you can't
even understand what people who believe
in another theory are saying
right you do that paradigm shift in your
mind uh so he later wrote another
paper where he said like no no there are
it's not an algorithm
choosing between scientific theories but
it is not irrational either
there are criteria people use simplicity
fruitfulness
you know predictability predictiveness
etc and
that's right like i don't know if his
list was right but the idea that it's
not an objective algorithm but
nevertheless it is not arbitrary either
that's what is at the heart of this
process of abduction
we can do our best to explain why
one hypothesis or another is the best
explanation
some people are going to disagree but as
we accumulate more and more data
the idea is we get better and better at
understanding which explanation
is better and this picture of abduction
in purse's
terms really fits much better
with this messy set of interconnected
activities
than the idea of logical induction or
deduction
ever did you know there's an example
that that purse gives
of looking out his window and seeing
azaleas
into the garden and he says you know i
would say
i see that there are azaleas out the
window and he goes well no you don't
what you see in in modern terms what you
see is some light hitting your eye right
some photons hitting your retina you
infer
the existence of azaleas because that is
the best way to explain that particular
pattern of light falling in my eyeball
you might be you might re remember that
this is more or less exactly the same
logic
we used when we talked about the past
hypothesis and the low entropy early
universe
we see the cosmic microwave background
it seems
pretty uniform to us and so you say
look the early universe had low entropy
because gravitational forces would have
pulled things together and made it
higher entropy
if it were lumpier rather than smooth
but you don't
see the early universe you see the light
you see the radiation field at your
eyeball now
you use the past hypothesis to infer
that there was probably uh that it was
consistent to say
there was a low entropy initial
condition so it's this sort of
consistency this back and forth what is
the simplest explanation what is the
most powerful what is the best
that's how science really works and
that's what purse was really getting at
you will also notice a very close
resemblance
between these ideas and bayesian
reasoning
it's basically the same thing to be
honest you can think of bayesian
reasoning
as a formalization of this abduction
procedure but
it makes it formal and therefore look
more systematic
but all of the loosey-gooseyness that i
mentioned in
abduction really is also there in
bayesian inference it's just hidden so
let me explain what i mean by that so
in bayesian reasoning you start with
some set of theories
that could be true right t i some
theories about the world
your theories could be oh i left my keys
in my car i left them
in my bedroom whatever like they don't
need to be grandiose physics theories
statements propositions about the world
and you assign to them some prior
probabilities right
priors some probability measure on the
space of all these
theories so that adds up to one okay and
these are your
prior probabilities that is to say
you're imagining in this little fake
scenario you have not yet looked at the
world
all of us have looked at the world so
it's a little bit fake so what account
is a prior and something that is
informed already
is a little bit tricky but that's okay
and then you use your theories
to make predictions and you collect data
d and so then you uh update
update your theories
to update your probabilities so you get
posterior
probabilities based on your prior
probabilities and your data
via phases rule which says that the
posterior
probability for theory i given the data
is the probability of the data given the
theory that is to say the likelihood
times the prior probability for that
theory divided by the net
probability for getting the data in all
the theories combined okay
bayes's rule right there so you can
update your theory so
the idea behind bayesian reasoning is um
in some sense you're doing abduction
you're saying i have a set of hypotheses
i want to figure out which is the best
explanation well what's the best
explanation
the one that predicted the data that i'm
going to get next
okay so if newton's theory says that
mercury should be doing one thing and
einstein's theories has issue doing
something else i then go and look at it
and i figure out which theory is more
likely and less likely
i chose that example explicitly because
it already brings up a problem
the motion of mercury was known about
the discrepancy of the motion mercury
was on about before general relativity
came on the scene
okay so what you call here a prior
probability
is already colored by the fact that you
know things about the world so bayesian
reasoning is correct
you know it's the right way to go update
your prior probabilities but it
hides a lot of the loosey-gooseyness
like i said so let me just bring some of
that
to the four okay um
let me just note some things about this
process and compare it with
what we've already said about science so
one is that the probability the prior
probabilities
for your theory set of theories and
even the posterior probabilities p of t
i given the data
should never
[Music]
be exactly zero or one okay
because if you thought like some theory
was just so dumb
i'm going to rule it out 100 percent
okay so it can't be right
what that would mean by baze's rule is
that no experiment you could ever do
could change your mind you have to just
good scientific practice this is not
built into bayesian analysis and in a
score
as far as baze's rule is concerned you
could by all means
set your priors equal to zero or one and
effectively if the prior is point zero
zero zero one then maybe you just set it
to zero to be
simple about it but as a rule of thumb
to be a good scientist you should never
set these exactly to zero or one because
you can always make mistakes and you can
always be surprised by data in
the future um that's that's kind of
obvious but here's something less
obvious the likelihood that's the
probability of the data given the theory
this is the thing that is the most
objective
supposed to be the most objective about
bayesian inference if you tell me the
theory
i should be able to predict the
likelihood i will get some data
right your priors are not objective
everyone can have their own priors right
you can argue about what is more simple
what is more elegant what is more likely
to be true
but then the idea is you collect your
data and that forces you to the truth
that's the hope and part of that process
is saying well
even if i don't know what my prior
probability on the theory is at least i
know what it predicts
but often you don't this is also
a messy thing remember einstein and the
expanding universe or contracting
universe
if we find some data that disagrees with
our theory
one absolutely legitimate option is to
tweak our theory
like who knows whether we got it right
the first time or not
that's an absolutely okay thing to do
furthermore as we said
very often you have a really good idea
whether it's inflation or curve space
time
or the many worlds interpretation or
string theory or whatever
or natural selection if you're darwin
right but you haven't yet articulated
the theory fully
so you have a vague idea that you would
like and hope it grows into
a fully blown theory someday but it's
not there yet
so it's hard to predict the data given
that theory that doesn't mean your
theory is wrong
right it just means i don't know what my
likelihood functions are that's
perfectly
legit that can that can happen um
then of course we have the question of
the priors
where do they come from so we already
mentioned
the zen in the art of motorcycle
maintenance problem uh where do the
theories come from
so even if i know the theories when i
had these credences
prior to doing experiments on different
theories being true where did those come
from like why do i think that a certain
theory is more likely another one a
priori
that's the reason why a lot of people
don't like bayesian analysis at all
because these priors play a really
crucial role in it and they seem
arbitrary
so what i'm trying to emphasize is yes
they are well sorry they're not
arbitrary but they're subjective
okay do you see the difference there
they're not objectively set by the world
there's not an algorithm that is
absolutely deterministic for telling you
what your prior should be
but they're not arbitrary either it
makes sense given a set of theories that
predict the same things
to prefer the simpler ones for a set of
theories that you know
are not yet fully developed yet prefer
the ones that seem to be more
developable
and you know more fruitful and make more
powerful predictions down the road
you can always rule them out by
collecting data
but there are reasons and this is what
[ __ ] was getting at there are reasons to
have
big or small priors for your theories um
finally an issue with that sort of the
the formula
basis formula here it sort of hides the
messiness right
another thing that it hides is what
about
the fact that you did not invent
every theory possible so what about
ti equals something else
that is to say let's say we're doing
quantum gravity okay
or whatever quantum gravity is a good
example and you say well it could be
string theory or it could be loop
quantum gravity or it could be causal
set theory or
be immersion space time entropic gravity
so the set of things i'm going to
assign prior probabilities to all of
these okay
but surely you have to admit that maybe
the correct theory of quantum gravity is
one that nobody has thought of yet
okay you need to assign some prior to
that
how do you do that number one and when
that is your theory my theory is it's
some theory i haven't invented yet
how in the world do you make a
prediction for the data on the basis of
that
right maybe you can approximate it or
something like that but
this factor down here the probability of
getting the data
depends on these likelihood functions
for all the theories
and if one of your theories is a theory
i haven't yet invented
that can be hard to specify so in very
clean crisp situations where you know
what every possibility is
you can do this in principle but in
science when you're
when you're confronting unknown features
of reality you have to admit
none of these equations none of these
factors none of these numbers
is absolutely objectively precisely
determined i need to be a little bit
more open
about the reality of it okay so
what i'm saying here in yet other words
um is
um science is hard to tidy up
it is very very difficult maybe
impossible but at least much harder than
it looks
to invent a theory of science
so to invent this algorithm that tells
you what happens when you do
science uh people try so here is i'm not
sure if this is a helpful diagram or not
but i'm going to draw a diagram anyway
here's how i think about it so
imagine that this is actual science okay
and
science let me say
science i don't know what the blob
represents but
the contours of it are you know inside
is what you're doing is science outside
what you're doing is not really science
maybe it is revelation or logic or
something else okay maybe it's just you
know you're
playing poker you have nothing to do
with science but there's some set of
human activities which we call science
some other set which we don't
and what people do is they try to
understand what this is you know what
counts the science and what doesn't
that's the demarcation problem
so what they do is they uh you know
invent a theory of what science is and
their theories inevitably
you know are nice and tidy right and
they sort of end up looking like this
they have nice sharp well-defined edges
and so this is your your idea about
science
it's much more crisp and clean and
easy to say what is and is not science
the problem with that is that sometimes
you'll hit
some thing that is really should
count as science and it does not fit
into your criteria
right you try to invent a theory of
science and
there's someone doing science but it
doesn't count according to your criteria
what you should say in that case is oh i
bet
my criteria were not perfect that my
theory of science was not exactly right
i should update it
but in fact what people say all the time
is oh that's not science what you're
doing what you're doing over there
that's not science i know you think it's
science but it's not because i have
figured out
what science is and it's not that okay i
think you know as much as i am a fan of
philosophy in general
this is something that that happens at
the boundary of philosophy
and science itself either philosophers
or scientists
try to come up with the correct once and
for all we're done with it philosophy of
science
and rather than updating that philosophy
when they understand something i didn't
understand before
they exposed facto excluded from
counting as science i think that's a
mistake
okay so let me give you a couple of
examples of what i mean
one is maybe you're too young to know
much about this but there's this idea
called methodological naturalism
it's a mouthful methodological
this again is a holdover from
[Music]
the days of fighting against creationism
in public schools which is a big thing
in the united states of america in the
80s 90s into the 2000s okay
so the idea of methodological naturalism
it's different than naturalism
so what naturalism is is the idea
there's only one universe one reality
okay the natural world the world that we
discover by science
that's what naturalism says and you
might call that metaphysical
naturalism or ontological naturalism
it's a statement about the nature of
reality reality is fully described
by the natural world there's no separate
supernatural world for example
methodological naturalism was the idea
that was completely invented
by people who were trying to fight
against creationism so with the best
intentions they said science
proceeds under the assumptions of
methodological naturalism
which is the assumption ahead of time
that when we go to explain some
observations
we do so in a naturalistic way in other
words
that the kinds of explanations that
science can come up with
are just in principle just a priori just
because we said so
naturalistic explanations so the idea of
methodological naturalism was
even if the true explanation for a
phenomenon was supernatural
science would never allow you to
contemplate that okay
and the reason why they came up with
this cockamamie scheme was they wanted
to be able to say
intelligent design should not be taught
in public schools so it was an entirely
political motive
okay not a philosophical or a scientific
one they wanted to say that this attempt
to bring religion to schools which is
what it was like intelligent design was
clearly just an attempt to smuggle
religion
into public school teaching um and they
wanted to argue against it by saying
well we
can't allow supernatural explanations in
science
okay but that's just wrong like nothing
that we said up here
had anything to do with what kinds of
explanations
are allowed we come up with the best
explanations that's whatever that's what
abduction says
whatever explanation fits the data the
best is the one that we like
if if you could convince me that there
is some data
for which the best explanation is to
assume that naturalism is wrong
then any good scientist will say
therefore naturalism is probably wrong
okay if an angel comes down you know
with a flaming sword and wings and so
forth and says all right i'm gonna
you know perform some miracles for you
now and this happens regularly and it
can't be explained by illusions or
trickery or laws of physics or anything
like that
or if you know all sorts of things
happen simultaneously throughout the
world to bring
true some predictions that were made by
some religious tradition
okay a good scientist would say well we
should at least consider
those explanations so the reason why you
should keep intelligent design out of
schools is not because it's
not science it's because it's bad
science
it's because they're not explaining
anything better than darwinian natural
selection ever would have
explained okay but that argument
seems a little bit more loosey-goosey
right like
you're not saying that something is cut
and dry disallowed you're saying it's
not very good
and then people can make an argument a
counter argument against that
what i'm here to say is yes that is
correct you need to
bite the bullet and make that hard
argument make the case
that this bad science should not be
taught because it is clearly just an
attempt to smuggle religion into your
schools okay you should not
invent weird philosophical principles
after the fact to justify your choice
you should be honest about how science
works
science is not methodologically natural
it is methodologically
so this is bad let's make this bad
that's not what science is what science
is or
a feature of science it is
methodologically oops
methodological
empiricism
in other words the the philosophical
presupposition of science is not what
kinds
of explanations we will allow but how we
decide
which explanations are correct namely we
do not appeal to revelation
we appeal to the data to looking at the
world we say like which of our
explanations is the best fit to the
empirical
information we get about the world and
we could always be wrong and we could
always try to do better
a more famous and more contentious
example
is of course karl popper's idea of
falsifiability this was very explicitly
an attempt on part of karl popper to
solve the demarcation problem to
separate what is science from what is
not science okay
um and just to be super duper clear here
i'm sure i will be misunderstood
because i've been down this road before
i do not know or care what karl popper
thought
i am not trying to say what popper said
i'm not trying to analyze the ideas in
karl popper's brain
or his writings okay i know that karl
popper has a lot of real fans out there
and i don't want to get them upset
it's a weird thing in philosophy people
care a lot
about what the great figures of history
really truly thought whereas in
physics or even science more generally
nobody cares like if
modern physicists knew what was going on
in isaac newton's mind
they'd be appalled but fortunately they
don't care what they care about is the
idea
okay so i'm not trying to do an exegesis
about what karl popper thought
what i'm trying to talk about is the
version of popper's idea
that has become popular among working
scientists
which is a literally a bumper sticker
slogan which says that
a theory is scientific only if it could
be falsified
that is to say uh not if it's false
right like if
a theory can still be scientific if it's
true but the idea is you could imagine
in this set of all possible worlds
you could imagine a set of experiments
you could do that would collect data
that would conflict
with the theory and this was a very good
idea that popper had
and what he was trying to distinguish
between were theories like
einstein's theory of general relativity
okay which made a prediction for the
deflection of light by the sun
which had it been wildly wrong you would
have said okay general relativity is not
right
versus something like freudian
psychoanalysis
which popper thought no matter what the
patient said
freud could come up with some
explanation after the fact so again i'm
also not
offering any um opinion about the
usefulness or correctness of freudian
psychoanalysis but that was the
distinction
that popper had in mind and now you know
from what we've said already that that's
not exactly right right because einstein
did
face examples of observational data that
he thought were
in conflict with the theory and he
didn't say oh my theory is wrong
he changed the theory to fit the data
and maybe he would have done the same
thing with a deflection of light or
something like that and that's
perfectly okay you're trying to look for
the best explanation not playing some
purity game
where if new data comes in that doesn't
fit your theory you're not allowed to
change your theory to update it and
improve it in any way
the real progress of science is much
messier than that
and it's a funny thing where
modern philosophers of science who for
their professional lives think about
what is science and what is not science
none of them it's an exaggeration almost
none of them
think that popper got the right answer
for the demarcation between science and
non-science
they think that he said something
important and true this is very often
the case in the history of philosophy
right someone says something interesting
and important captures
some part of what we're trying to get at
without getting the final answer
but scientists many many scientists
think that he just got the right answer
right and honestly it's a little bit
unfair for me to say a little bit
uncharitable but i think that
they just like it because it's simple
right the falsifiability criterion fits
on a bumper sticker
and they can you know it can help them
understand what is science and what is
not
but it completely uh is subject to this
problem that there are edge cases uh
general relativity is not an edge case
but there are other cases that
we'll talk about just in a second where
it's less clear how to apply
this idea of falsifiability um
what so what popper did get right
so the good part of this criterion was
he was getting at something real and
true okay if you think about
psychoanalysis versus gender relativity
popper was trying to say the reason why
gr is a really good theory is because i
could in
potentially hypothetically
if it were wrong i could show that it
was wrong whereas a theory that is so
vague and malleable doesn't really count
as scientific that was his idea
so the the the things that he was
getting at which are true is that a good
scientific theory is definite
in other words it's not infinitely
flexible right there are things that it
would explain or would account for would
predict
and things that it would not allow for
if this were true then the theory would
be wrong
and that it is judged by empirical
criteria that is to say ultimately we
want to look at the data
so these features that popper was
getting at are true
features of science a definite theory is
better than a fuzzy theory
and you do want to compare your theory
with the observations
it's just that in both cases the actual
application to real world examples of
science
in progress are not nearly as cut and
dried as popper would have us believe or
rather
sorry as modern scientists cartoon
version of popper that they carry around
in their minds
would have us believe it's messier than
that right it's more complicated so
uh persian
explanation is a better model for what
science does
because that's what popper was sort of
getting at
um the real problem with
again popper's view of freud not
necessarily with freud which i have no
opinion about but popper's view of freud
was
it doesn't explain anything because it
could explain anything
right there's nothing that could happen
that the theory would say no no that
that can't happen that that doesn't make
sense at all
right if that's true if your theory
really could be bent and twisted
to explain anything then it doesn't
explain anything
that act of explanation distinguishes
things that could happen from things
that couldn't happen
and that's already there in abduction in
the persian model of inference to the
best explanation
because if you just predict anything
could possibly happen you haven't
explained
the actuality of why certain things
happen at all
so this this you know abduction model is
less algorithmic less cut and dried less
crystal clear
okay how we draw the dividing line but
it's more accurate it's more close to
what actually
happens and let's uh let's fill in some
of the details here by looking at a
couple of famous examples okay let's
look at the many worlds interpretation
of quantum mechanics here is a famous
example
where people say this is not a good
scientific theory because it's not
falsifiable it's not hard to find people
who say that now
popper didn't say that popper knew about
the many world's interpretation of
quantum mechanics he didn't like it as a
theory he didn't promote it
he had his own interpretation of quantum
mechanics which really never got off the
ground
um but he vastly preferred everett's
theory
to the copenhagen interpretation because
he said look ever it makes sense
you know it's a definite theory whereas
copenhagen is kind of the mess
it's not a definite theory at all and
definiteness was part of what he was
trying to get at
the issue is i think it's with people
not who misunderstand the philosophy of
science but with people who
misunderstand
the many world's interpretation they
think that the many worlds
interpretation
starts by saying there are a lot of
worlds and they're all
non-interacting and you cannot ever know
that they're there okay
these worlds are constantly coming into
existence and therefore
there there's a whole bunch of stuff in
the universe which we can never observe
and what they say is i cannot imagine
how to falsify
that claim right that is the argument i
hope i hope i'm doing it justice
the claim that there are many many other
worlds out there
seems to be falsifiable but if you
understand
the many world's interpretation you know
that the claim that there are many many
worlds out there
is not the many world's interpretation
it is a prediction
based on the many world's interpretation
many worlds is just
there's a wave function psi which is an
element of hilbert's base
and psi obeys the schrodinger equation h
psi i'll make it a capital psi
equals i d by dt psi
that's the many worlds interpretation
right and then you use this mathematical
formalism to predict
that there are other worlds out there
could you possibly falsify the many
worlds theory of course
you can in fact there are experiments
going on right now that would do it
namely experiments looking for
violations of the schrodinger equation
looking for experiments that see wave
functions explicitly evolve in ways that
are not
the schrodinger equation if any of those
experiments come true
many worlds is falsified so i don't see
what they're complaining about
but more importantly i mean i get i get
the
uh sort of psychological
um what should i say the the motivation
behind their claim they they know that
many worlds predicts things we can't see
and they don't like that that seems to
be in violation of the spirit
if not the letter of the law as far as
falsifiability is concerned
but again that's not a philosophy of
science problem that's just a quantum
mechanics problem
everett claims that under this very
simple set of rules you predict the
existence of other worlds now
maybe he's wrong maybe there's something
that we got wrong about the
interpretation
of these equations uh which says that
there is not another world in which the
cat is awake and another world in which
the cat is asleep okay
if that's true by all means explain why
we have misunderstood the schrodinger
equation and
coherence and so forth but the only
other option
is that these postulates of many worlds
are wrong
one or the other of them either there's
other stuff
in the world in addition to the wave
function or the wave function is not the
world at all it's just a completely
different kind
of thing or the wave function does not
obey the schrodinger equation
so if you're truly bothered by these
other worlds the the
the result the the suggestion is not
that you say well it's not falsified
falsifiable therefore it's not science
the suggestion is you
come up with a theory that explains why
the other worlds aren't there
and then i could ask about how to test
that theory
right but right now since we don't have
any other well we have other theories
that do try to do exactly that the grw
theory tries to do exactly that and
guess what
we're trying to test it so honestly you
know i'm
i'm being a little bit uncharitable here
a little bit a little bit uh
rhetorically
overheated but the point is many worlds
is not in any sense an example of a
non-falsifiable non-scientific theory
that's just bad
physics to think that you might not like
many worlds for other reasons that's
perfectly okay
there are good objections to many worlds
but this is not one of them
the other example closely related to
this is the cosmological multiverse okay
a little bit different worth rehearsing
why it's different
the multiverse is the idea that for some
reason or another there's different
uh reasons why this could come to pass
but there are different regions of the
universe
different regions of space-time they're
just far away they're not like the
everetti and multiverse where they are
appearing
literally simultaneously existing and
with no
spatial relationship between them
there's just a place
far away maybe impossible to get to if
you can't go faster than the speed of
light
where conditions are very different okay
and if that's true
a bunch of things follow this the thing
that follows most
strongly is that would change your
opinion about whether or not certain
features of our observable universe
are natural okay so it doesn't make a
strong prediction this cosmological
multiverse idea
it doesn't predict something falsifiable
in the strict
sense right it doesn't unlike everett
that does if you see the wave function
evolve in a non-schrodinger way
you falsified it the cosmological
multiverse
is a set of ideas that you cannot
directly falsify
now just like everett the cosmological
multiverse is not really by itself
a theory just in the sense that the many
worlds are not a theory
they are a prediction of a theory
however in this case the theories that
predict the cosmological multiverse are
much
less well defined than ever reading
quantum mechanics is
you talk about inflation and eternal
inflation and string theory in the
landscape evacuate all these things
all these are in the category of those
vague ideas that are not yet fully
fleshed out so even those ideas unlike
the schrodinger equation those ideas of
inflation and string theory
those are not themselves falsifiable but
the multiverse
in that version of the multiverse is a
prediction
of those theories and what you would
want to falsify are those theories not
the multiverse
but what i want to say is that this is
just an example of where the idea of
falsifiability is leading us
astray it's a perfect example of
perfectly good science that people are
criticizing not because it's bad science
but because they tried to invent in
their heads what counted as good science
and this didn't fit
so they decided after the fact that this
was not good science uh
the multiverse the question from the
point of view of abduction or bayesian
inference or whatever you want to call
it
the question is is it conceivable
that the best explanation of the
universe we do observe
invokes a cosmological multiverse right
that's the question we should be asking
and you might say well even if it is the
best explanation how would we ever know
for
sure you'll never know for sure you
never know anything for sure that's how
science works right
not proving things for sure the question
is is it the best explanation
that we have and so once you ask it that
way
in principle the answer is clearly
possibly yes so i'm not saying the
multiverse is true or false
but it's absolutely conceivable that
it's true and that we decide that it's
true
down the road so it can play an
explanatory role
it can even let me finish writing
it can even make predictions for example
for the cosmological constant
this is the cosmos constant okay capital
lambda um
stephen weinberg 10 years before
we discovered the acceleration of the
universe sat down and thought about the
cosmological multiverse and he said you
know
if there is a multiverse out there then
there'll be places where the cosmos
constant's really big
places where it's negative but we can't
live with those places if it's big and
positive
it blows us apart if it's big and
negative the universe re-collapses
therefore i make a prediction namely
that
number one the cosmological constant is
small
because otherwise i couldn't be here but
number two there's no reason for it to
be zero
okay that was the crucial part before
then
physicists theoretical physicists knew
that the cosmological constant was much
smaller than it
should be on the basis of quantum field
theory and renormalization group
arguments and effective field theories
um so they said well i don't know why
it's so small
but it is much much smaller than it
should be therefore there's probably
some symmetry or some principle that
sets it equal to zero
this is the example that we talked about
earlier what about one of when
what about when one of your theories is
a theory i haven't yet invented okay
physicists put a large prior probability
for the cosmos constant on a theory we
haven't yet invented that sets it equal
to zero
when weinberg analyzed the cosmological
multiverse he realized that
here is a theory that can explain why
lambda is small
but it predicts something different than
that
theories i haven't yet invented but have
some symmetry principle
idea namely that it should be not quite
zero there's no reason
for the cosmological constant to be
exactly zero just for us to be here it
can be small and not quite zero
so guess what in 1998
when we discovered that the universe is
accelerating that was
predicted by the cosmological multiverse
in
this sense so it is just
true from the bayesian perspective that
the probability of the multiverse
went up
when we discovered well in 1998 yeah
when we discovered i should write it out
the acceleration of the universe
why because we learned a new fact about
the universe
that has small but not zero cosmological
constant that one could argue was
better explained by the cosmological
multiverse then the big bucket of ideas
that just set lambda equal to zero in
other words
you had a likelihood function
big bucket of theories that says lamb
equals zero says
that it predicts that lambda is zero
multiverse
says that it predicts with a certain
probability that lambda is not zero
lambda is not zero therefore your
bayesian probability your posterior
probability
on the multiverse went up likewise
probability of the multiverse
could go down
if we invent a better explanation
a better theory
so that's also completely allowed if i
tomorrow
uh now that i'm not making videos
anymore if i finally sit down and write
down the correct theory of the
cosmological constant and i publish it
and it predicts on the basis of you know
the mass of the electron
what exactly the cosmological constant
should be and it's no multiverse it's
just a formula that gets the right
answer
then people's prior people's credence
that the multiverse is real
will go down not to zero because it
should never go all the way to zero but
it should go down
so i want to mention these two things
because look the first one
discovering the acceleration of the
universe this is extremely
empirical this is data this is an
experiment that was a surprising
experiment
that changed our opinions on the
credences for the multiverse or for not
the multiverse
that you don't get more scientific than
that you don't get more
real world empirical data-driven than
that your credence has changed because
of a new experimental discovery
okay um but the other one is also
important
your credences can also change just
because of a non-experimental
discovery right um there's a there's a
controversy going on in this talk about
string theory in the multiverse
uh richard david who is uh uh
he used to be a string theorist he
turned into a philosopher of physics and
he's
been writing about you know don't think
about falsifiability and he coined this
term non-empirical theory confirmation
or non-empirical confirmation
and this was it's too bad when he uh
coined this term for two reasons one is
because
the word confirmation is used in a
technical sense by philosophers that is
different than what it means to
everybody else
to everyone else when you say you've
confirmed something you mean
you've shown that it is true right
you've confirmed it it's true
i've shown it right in philosophy of
science literature
confirmation is any kind of
consideration that changes your
credences for something
up or down right so what david means by
non-empirical confirmation is not that
you can
prove a theory right just by thinking
about it
what he means is that by thinking about
it might change your credences
one way or the other and look this is
obviously true okay if we think about a
theory and discover that it predicts
even more things uh that it's even
simpler
and even more robust than we thought or
contrary wise
that there's a much better theory that
explains all the same things that is
much
more simple and elegant and more
fruitful than the theory we have
of course our ideas about the credences
that we put on these theories are going
to change
so the one so i said there's two things
that bugged me about it one is it's a
bad word
confirmation he didn't mean confirmation
in the usual sense he just meant
changes in your credences from
non-empirical means
and inventing a better theory is
definitely an example of that
um so for the example i like to give is
um
you know we had in i said in 1960s
quantum field theory wasn't even very
popular right
and um one of the reasons why there were
all sort of mathematical
puzzles so higgs and brown and anglair
had come up with the higgs mechanism
weinberg had already said well it could
help explain the masses of the particles
and their symmetries etc
but no one paid any attention you
literally looked the stephen weinberg's
paper for a long time
was the most highly cited paper in all
of particle physics in the history of
particle physics
but in the first like three years after
he published it there were maybe one or
two citations of it no one paid any
attention
and the reason why is because we didn't
think it was renormalizable
we didn't think you could make
mathematical sense of that spontaneously
broken symmetry in the same way
you could have quantum electrodynamics
okay so in the early 1970s gerard
tuft showed that the spontaneously
broken
symmetry of the electro weak theory was
renormalizable
it's a mathematical proof and suddenly
people's credences
in the higgs mechanism and the electric
weak theory increased by an enormous
amount
okay you can see the you can literally
see the credences affect the number of
citations for weinberg's paper and for
higgs's paper etc
nothing wrong with that but it was not
new data
it was non-empirical changes in
credences because we
understood the theory better right and
that's exactly this is so the second
thing that bugs me about
david's formulation is there's nothing
new here
it's not like we're applying the thing
that i disagree with
about philosophers who try to defend
string theory by saying it's a new way
of doing science that we need to have
in the this modern age it's the old way
of doing science there's nothing new
about it
the only thing new it's not really new
but the only thing that might think make
you think it's new is that it's hard
when we talk about the foundations of
quantum mechanics or the cosmological
multiverse or
theories of quantum gravity like string
theory it is very often the case that
the kinds of predictions that they make
are hard to test so
that means that life is tough for us
right that means that we can't get the
answer
quickly or easily that doesn't mean the
answer is not
gettable it doesn't mean it's not
science in some sense
okay so it's hard but it's not a
fundamental
paradigm shift in how science is done
it's just that you know
and look maybe we'll never be finished
maybe a million years from now
scientists when they are asked is there
a cosmological multiverse or not we'll
just say
i don't know 50 50 40 60 something like
that
okay there's no guarantee that we will
converge and there's certainly no
guarantee that we will converge on any
short time scale
that's not part of the scientific method
but that doesn't mean it's not
science it just means it's hard that's
okay
all right i've been going on a long time
losing my voice i'm going to have
something to sip here but um i'm not
going to stop
because i did want to talk just a little
bit about
that's all i have to say about what is
science let's talk about fundamental
physics
and its uh potential what's going to
happen in the future
what is the prognosis for the future as
well as the president of fundamental
physics
and i don't as i've said before i don't
love the phrase fundamental physics but
you know what i mean the kinds of ideas
the kinds of concepts the kinds of
physics that we've been talking about in
the biggest ideas series right
um elementary physics basic down to
earth reductionistic physics okay
so we're in this really weird position
when it comes to that stuff when it
comes to the stuff that i do
for a living we have good theories very
very very good theories
of gravity
right we have general relativity gr
uh we have good theories of cosmology
vaguely speaking the hot big bang model
and not bottle
uh as we talked about in the cosmology
video there's a hot big bang event
there's the moment the singularity and
forget about that that's not what we're
talking about
the scenario under which the universe
starts in a hot dense state
expands and cools and galaxies form
that's the hot big bang model
you can embed it with some by fixing
some parameters right about you know
what the density of certain things
is what the perturbation spectrum looks
like stuff like that
that's the hot big model that we meet
that we mean when we say the standard
model of cosmology
and then of course for particle physics
we have the boringly named standard
model
and it looks like huddle um
so that's good i mean it's not bad to
have good theories that you're trying to
um invent when you're trying to explain
the world this is a triumph this is an
amazing fact right
uh you know a hundred and
20 years ago the year 1900 we didn't
have any of these things
right we have all these very very good
theories of
really deep facts about nature that we
developed in the last 120 years
okay the bad news is that the theories
are too good
that the predictions made by these
theories have raced ahead
of our ability to do new experiments and
undermine these theories remember how do
you win the nobel prize in physics
not by showing your theory is correct
right not by
propping up the establishment but by
overthrowing the theories
so the question is not how do we how can
we possibly confirm these theories over
and over again
the question is how do we undermine them
how do we go beyond them
okay so there haven't been that many
surprises
in fundamental physics in my lifetime
there was a big surprise i counted as a
big surprise in 1998 when we found the
universe was accelerating
obviously it was known that could happen
i was the co-author on
a review article on the cosmos constant
came out years before we discovered it
um but most of us didn't think that it
was actually true that there was vacuum
energy in the universe so i count 1998
as a big
surprise there haven't been big
surprises in
gravity theory in the theory itself you
know do we modify general relativity
since it was invented general relativity
is the same today that it was when
einstein wrote it down
over 100 years ago in particle physics
the last
big surprising things were in the 1970s
right that we were still putting the
standard model together
quarks were still sort of a little bit
uh not yet established protons inside
asymptotic freedom uh the later
generations you know the tao and the top
and the bottom quarks
these all came about in the 1970s big
surprises
since then we've had plenty of
discoveries in all of these areas
we found gravitational waves evidence
for black holes
cmb perturbations and the beautiful
spectrum of temperature fluctuations in
the microwave background
evidence for dark matter and dark energy
the w and the z
bosons the top quark and higgs boson
found all those things okay
but they were all part other than the
acceleration of the universe they were
all kind of part
of what we expected of what we had
predicted okay
and that's good except nobody thinks
that we're done you know it would be one
thing
if we thought we had the final theory of
any of these areas
but we know we don't you know in gravity
we have a theory that is not compatible
with quantum mechanics
um in cosmology we have a theory that
doesn't explain the initial conditions
we don't yet know what the dark matter
is
some people think we don't even know
what the dark energy is right okay so
there's plenty of open questions there
in particle physics obviously there's a
whole bunch of problems why do we have
the particular
set of masses and couplings and so forth
that we do let me um
yeah so anyway standard modern particle
physics doesn't include gravity it's not
completely unified there's a whole bunch
of things that we think
are not quite there yet so
when you're in a situation where you
have a bunch of theories
and they all fit all the data like
there's literally no data that is wildly
in conflict with all these theories like
you can
argue around the edges you know
neutrinos have masses so do you count
neutrino masses as being part of the
standard model or not
who cares okay i think you can just
stick them in there it's not a big deal
you have theories that fit the data but
they're not right they're not the final
answer in the sense of
that sense of being right so how do you
make progress scientific progress is
usually driven not by brilliant
theoretical
proposals but by experimental data that
doesn't fit the theories
the there are brilliant theoretical
proposals but usually after
you've done the experiment and shown
that it doesn't fit your theoretical
prediction
so the question is are there hopes for
future discoveries that would be
surprising and lead us
somewhere so what are the possible
future discoveries
of course we're looking right we're not
done and no one is sitting on their
laurels
so let's think about what they could be
um for gravity
you know uh i'm just gonna say it's
unlikely that's that's all i'm gonna say
and i say this as someone who has
written papers
suggesting modified theories of gravity
okay so
nobody would be happier than me if
einstein were wrong
if there is some way uh that gravity
beyond general relativity was really
really important in
astrophysics or cosmology i would love
that idea it's an awesome idea
uh i'll tell you why it's unlikely
number one it's not at all what you
should expect
from first principles remember if you go
back to the video we did on
renormalization
where we talked about effective field
theories um
in field theory generally speaking what
you expect is that given
knowledge at some energy scale or length
scale
you can extrapolate that knowledge
safely to lower energies
and larger distances you cannot always
extrapolate that knowledge to shorter
distances or higher energies
but the fact that we figured out general
relativity here in the solar system
makes us think we probably understand it
on cosmological scales
and so far after decades and decades and
decades of trying
all of the data that we have says yes we
do understand it so
you can work hard as a theorist you can
like really stretch your brain
to try to come up with ways to modify
gravity
at large distances in ways that would
not show up
here in the solar system but it's hard
and it's not natural
uh very often people say all right i've
invented new theory i've done this i've
invented a new theory
um that changes gravity in the infrared
at long distances and someone else says
up here's an experiment that is already
in conflict with it okay that's what
happens over and over again
so it's not what you would expect
there's no evidence for it and there's
no need for it
there's no data that says you can't
explain this without modifying gravity
right
it's still possible we should keep it
open as a possibility that gravity is
different
on astrophysical scales than gr but i'm
just going to tell you the truth and
judge it to be
unlikely i'm glad that some people are
trying
to develop those theories and test them
against data because that's the only way
to know for sure
but my prior is small that that theory
that that approach is going to work
uh in cosmology there's a lot more hope
um for discovering new things you know
uh
we can find things there's a whole bunch
of things we could discover like
cmb anomalies i'll just say
what i mean by that is we have the
cosmic microwave background
the leftover radiation from the big bang
and the kobe satellite in 1992 show that
there were slight variations in
temperature
from place to place on the sky which are
primordial which came from the very very
early universe
you know by the way this is another
example of the progress of science
when i was your age there were a whole
bunch of people who took very very
seriously the idea that the
perturbations in density that lead to
galaxies came from something like cosmic
strings
okay and cosmic strings made a
prediction for what you should see in
the microwave background which was
utterly different
than the prediction you get from
inflationary cosmology and inflation was
spot on
and cosmic strings were ruled out there
could still be cosmic strings but they
are not the origin
of the density perturbations that we see
in the universe today progress
on the basis basis of data okay
we have a model a sort of
phenomenological model
with a small number of free parameters
that fits the cmp data
perfectly well an anomaly is something
that wouldn't
fit into that model so what we say is
there are perturbations on all scales
it's interesting because you know we
talked in the last video about
power laws and scale-free behavior and
the universe
the perturbations in the universe seem
to be scale-free to a very good
approximation
does that speak to some generative model
that produces them in some interesting
way i don't know that's a very good
question inflation might be an example
of that but that's the kind of thing
that's worth thinking about
anyway um are there
the the it's not exactly flat the
spectrum so when i say the spectrum here
i mean well i can draw it i have a
pad here so here are perturbations in
density delta rho
over rho as a function of scale in the
early universe and roughly
in the early universe we think that they
were just flat okay i'll just draw the
straight line
but not exactly it can be tilted a
little bit in fact the best fit to the
data has it tilt a little bit
but if there were a bump or something
like that that would count as an anomaly
that would be something very very
different
other things that would count as
anomalies are gravitational waves from
the early universe we can hope to find
them but we haven't yet that's a
prediction of inflation
but the amount of them is not predicted
by inflation
we could find what are called
non-gaussianities which means that the
different modes of fluctuation
somehow conspire like all their peaks
are in one area
and or other troughs in some other area
not what is predicted
by the simplest models but you could
mock up more complicated models that
predict them
maybe there are what are called power
asymmetry
in the cosmic microwave background um
there's another thing i've worked on
myself so
you imagine that not only is the
temperature different in one direction
versus another
but the amount of fluctuations is
different in one direction
or another there's a little bit of hint
uh that that might actually be true
in the data there's something called the
axis of evil that you can look up online
if you want
sadly it's hard to google that because
there's another meaning for access of
evil but people have talked about this
anyway the point is there's a lot of
possible ways that future observations
of the microwave background could lead
to discoveries
that are a little bit different than
what we find that what we have predicted
in our current
best model the bad news is that
none of them are smoking none of them
are sure things
there it is we have a model that
predicts what we see now
that model might continue to be true as
we just get better and better and better
data it's not like the higgs boson where
we had a missing piece
of the standard model so we could really
say with confidence we'll find something
at the large hadron collider even though
we don't know what it is
for the microwave background we might
just keep finding what we've already
found over and over again we might not
so be optimistic
but we might and then of course there
are is dark matter
what is it that's a big looming question
is it weakly interacting with particles
is it black holes is it axions is it
neutrinos
if we find that that'd be great if we
actually detect directly the dark matter
that's a huge
another surprising discovery no matter
what it is that we find um
the standard model is not up to the task
of explaining the dark matter
but the bad news is we have to admit
there's a certain credence that says
there is dark matter and we'll never
detect it directly
right we'll just do not have the
experimental reach to find out exactly
what it is
i hope that's not true and i don't
actually think it's true that's
something i don't think is very likely
but it could be hard to find if there's
e it's easy to invent
theories of dark matter that fit all the
data they'll be very very hard to test
experimentally there you go um and then
dark energy
you know the simplest idea for dark
energy is the cosmological constant but
it could be
not quite constant it could be slightly
variable again
i've written papers about this i've
constructed models i've thought about
this myself i'd be very happy if it were
true
having done that and having seen there's
no evidence for it and having seen that
theories that try to predict it often
run afoul of data elsewhere
my credence that that is true is small
these days i think that the dark energy
is probably just the cosmological
constant
i think there's nothing more
experimentally to be discovered about it
i hope i'm wrong but that is my
prediction
so you get the you know you get the uh
the feeling for what i'm saying here
namely that
you could find things but i'm not quite
sure how likely it is
and then just to finish that off for
particle physics
well we have this huge looming problem
in particle physics we had real hopes
for the large hadron collider because we
have the hierarchy problem
which we talked about before um the
hierarchy problem
in the most naive way of saying it is
that there's an energy
scale associated with the electro weak
theory right with the weak interactions
and how they
have a symmetry that gets split off from
the
electromagnetic interactions at around
has an energy scale of around
10 to the 2 billion electron volts gev
right near the mass of the higgs and the
top and other
particles and this number is just much
much less
than the planck scale which is around 10
to the 18
gb so you might say well gravity has
nothing to do with particle physics but
the
philosophy of effective field theory
that we talked about
predicts that the electro weak scale
should be as high as possible
it doesn't want to be low it wants to be
big so
this is not a direct conflict between
theory and observation it's just a
violation of our expectations
okay it just doesn't seem right doesn't
seem natural so people tried very hard
to invent theories that would explain
the hierarchy problem and for better for
worse they did there were lots of
explanations
super symmetry was the most popular one
but there were large extra dimension
models
uh infinitely big extra mentioned models
a whole bunch of other different models
that purported to explain the hierarchy
problem
what they had in common was they
predicted
particles new particles
at the lhc or at lhc
energies and we didn't find any i mean
there were people who said you know with
some
trepidation but with also some
seriousness we will turn on the lhc
and gluino's supersymmetric partners of
the gluon will just come spewing out so
it'll be impossible to ignore
that did not happen right um maybe it
will
you know the lac is not turned off yet
it's going to run for years decades more
maybe we'll find something but it hasn't
yet and
we have to at least step up to the
possibility to the prospect that it
won't
uh that those are all the particles
there at the electroweak scale
maybe there are particles beyond there
maybe not and so where that leaves us
with
is these theories that do a very good
job of fitting the data we don't think
they're right we need to move beyond
them
an experiment is not telling us how
[Music]
you know in some sense what i'd like to
say is you know we're really spoiled by
the first half of the 20th century i
think i've already mentioned this in
these videos but
um in the first half of the 20th century
we invented quantum mechanics we
invented all these theories right we
invented quantum mechanics
quantum field theory general relativity
special relativity we even invented the
big bang right the expansion of the
universe and all that stuff
first half of the 20th century it was so
good so anomalously good
for physics that in some rough sense
is a bit unfair but you get the point
the second half of the 20th century was
spent
cleaning up all the discoveries we made
from the first half of the 20th century
okay trying to understand them at a
deeper level
and that leaves us here in the 21st
century
not knowing exactly how to move forward
so
how do we move forward what are the
strategies given the situation
and again it's not a bad situation it's
no one no one's failure no one has made
a mistake
right it's just that nate we our our
theories are too good
we've explained what we observed in
nature this is not some crisis because
physicists lack imagination
right it's because physicists or
imagination is too good we've imagined
enough to fit the data
what more do you want than that it's
nature that is at fault here nature is
not giving us any experimental
clues so what do we do next um
i'll mention three strategies these are
literally strategies that might be
followed by
actual physicists and i'm imagining that
maybe there's some physicists listening
they're not going to listen to my advice
but maybe there are some young people
listening who want to know what they
should do if they want to go into
physics
the first and most obvious strategy is
to press on
in other words we have
a set of strategies that has been
productive for the last hundred years
okay we write down models of particle
physics and cosmology you know here's a
model for the dark matter the dark
energy the hierarchy problem the grand
unification
we make predictions and we try to do
experiments that test those predictions
so we build an experiment
uh that collides particles together at
ever higher energies or we build a
better telescope that looks at the
microwave background
or or what have you okay and we hope
that we discover something new and
surprising
let me be very very clear this is a very
good strategy
okay this is not a bad strategy this is
not a failure of imagination this is the
most
sensible thing to do it is the thing
that has worked
empirically over the course of time
but we also have to be fair in saying
that there is something different now
than there used to be the thing that is
different is that we don't have a target
to shoot for okay when we had the higgs
boson
we had gravitational waves or we had the
cosmic microwave background anisotropies
when those things had not yet
been discovered we in some sense had a
pretty good idea what to look for and
what we would find
when we looked there unless there was
some even more surprising thing that we
would find right
um we have no strong predictions
for what will come next what is the
thing that will surprise us
so if you want to say like should we
spend
i don't know 25 billion dollars building
a next generation particle experiment
um in a world of infinite money
that is absolutely a worthwhile thing to
do because you might discover something
that changes everything that overthrows
all of known physics and changes things
in a really wild way
but you might also discover literally
nothing at all you might do nothing more
than measure some parameters that we've
already measured but measure them to
higher precision
okay and i can't tell you what the
chances are so in a world of a finite
amount of money
the answer is my answer is i don't know
what to do
i would prefer if we did it i would
prefer if we spent a lot of money doing
next generation particle physics
number one if we don't we will lose all
that expertise we will forget how to
build
giant particle accelerators okay number
two
every time we build a giant particle
accelerator it comes with unintended
benefits
you know people have done this like this
when i wrote my book
the particle the end of the universe
people did an economic cost-benefit
analysis
and they discovered that by putting
money into building giant particle
accelerators
it increases the economic output by much
more than you
spent on building the accelerator not
because you discovered the higgs boson
but because you build better computers
better communication equipment you know
better radiation
safe detectors and things like that it's
a good
payoff to build very high quality
physics experiments
um on the other hand it's going to be an
international
experiment you're going to need
cooperation between different countries
the united states of america sadly has
proven over the last few decades
that we are terrible international
partners that we are not capable
of following through on our commitments
so if there is a next generation giant
particle accelerator
it is very very unlikely we built here
in the united states
different locations in asia are thought
of or europe
are thought of so we'll have to see what
happens so i hope it happens i'm rooting
for it
but i'm very very cognizant of the fact
that there's no guarantees it might not
find
anything still worth doing and that's
worth doing
not only experimentally but
theoretically as well building new
models
of beyond standard model particle
physics inflationary cosmology of dark
matter it's worth doing
it's just hard to know where to look
like as a working theorist
i am no longer motivated to do that kind
of stuff because the chances of success
just seem to be small for any one theory
someone's going to get it right
someone's going to move me on the
standard model and figure out what the
right thing is but the chance that it's
any one person is pretty small because a
lot of people
trying to do it so the another strategy
is
to dig deep or dig deeply
dig deeply deeper by which i mean
rather than building yet another model
for inflation
or for particle physics step back
take a breath think about the
underpinnings
of these theories that we have quantum
mechanics
right foundations of quantum mechanics
quantum field theory
is quantum field theory the be all and
end all like how necessary
is it what are the theorems we can prove
about the relationship of quantum field
theory to underlying structures
um cosmology the big bang what happened
before inflation is inflation
really a solution to the problems it
proports to be a solution to you know i
talked about inflation in the
q a for what we did a cosmology video
i talked about inflation in particular
in the q a video for the cosmology video
um you know the multiverse
raises some interesting philosophical
questions i don't just mean like what
does it all mean with if there's a
multiverse i mean at a down and dirty
calculational level
i said that weinberg made a prediction
was that prediction justified
how do you make predictions in a
multiverse right like what is the
philosophy of probability
in this context so all of these are
foundational questions
which if we were if we had successful
theories but were confronted with a
bunch of new experimental
data that was in conflict with them
maybe the underlying foundational
questions would be less urgent
right maybe the most high priority thing
would be to explain the data
that we found but we're not in that
situation and we're in a situation where
the things that the theories that we
have fit pretty well but we know they're
not the final answer
maybe taking a step back and thinking
more deeply about where those theories
come from what their underlying
philosophical
presuppositions and how they could be
changed how you could predict different
things maybe that's the thing to do and
that's actually you know you know
listening to me that's my view
personally this is my
personal idiosyncratic favorite way of
moving forward given the situation we're
in right now
not for everyone i hope it's not for
everyone like let a thousand flowers
bloom
in this i'm glad different people have
different opinions about what to do
and the final strategy is to just change
direction
in other words if what you care about is
fundamental physics
start caring about something other than
fundamental physics right a lot of
people do this a lot of people who were
trained in quantum field theory are now
thinking about quantum computers
or biophysics or machine learning or
something like that
um i personally have interested in
complex systems which we talked about in
the last video which is not
fundamental in the same sense although
there's something fundamental-ish about
it
perfectly valid way of moving forward
like maybe
a thousand years from now historians of
science will look back and say yeah
20th century man they really overturned
the foundations of physics in a really
important way
and then things more or less settle down
for the next 500 years
before we came up with new fundamental
discoveries in physics
maybe i don't think so i don't think
that's very very likely but it's
possible and there's certainly plenty to
be discovered and learned in other areas
of physics or science or intellectual
activity
more broadly so if what you want to do
is something that isn't fundamental
physics at all
uh godspeed more power to you i think
that's a perfectly valid uh way to go
anyway uh we're closing up we're we're
shutting down
we're i'm going to turn off i'm going to
get rid of my green screen i'm going to
turn off my lights
um the videos are have come to an end
here uh
i think that science is in great shape
you know this
science is the topic of this video in
the in the series
science is doing great let's not be uh
let's not forget that
science is awesome as we said at the
beginning of the video physics is
awesome there's a lot of new discoveries
coming down
this specific subset of really deep
questions in fundamental physics
uh progress recently has been slow
the problems are really really hard
there's no
guarantee that progress will always be
fast or will always be at the same rate
in my eyes these problems are worth
working on right worth thinking about in
a very
deep way worth spending our intellectual
effort because
it's the most fundamental questions that
we have the nature of the universe the
nature of reality
what is space what is time what are we
made of right i
even think as i argued in my book the
big picture that what we learn about
fundamental physics
has an impact on our lives and
self-conception as human beings right
it's an indirect effect but i think that
it's there so i think
thinking about these things working to
make progress is important i especially
think
that it's crucially important not to
become armchair
about it right like i'm an armchair
physicist i don't do experiments
but the field needs experiments we even
if we don't have a direct target to
shoot for
the field is kept vibrant by trying
to find new experimental results and
trying to overthrow the current theories
we have to keep
moving on that so what i want to do is
just to work hard
at understanding the world um see what
happens
and you know i'm sure that our
descendants many generations from now
will look back at what we're doing right
now
and say both that we were brilliant and
that we were very silly
right because that's what we always say
like every generation you look back at
you know 1900
plunk and einstein and all those people
on the one hand you can say all the
brilliant things they did
boltzmann and uh boar and so forth they
so many brilliant ideas but in some ways
they were deeply silly like they missed
some things that were right in front of
their noses they just couldn't see them
i'm sure we're missing something that is
right in front of our noses and that's
one of the reasons why
i want to make videos like this spread
the excitement spread the ideas and the
open questions to as many people as
possible you know i think that um
the the professional activity of getting
paid to do a job
of being a theoretical physicist is and
always will be available to only a small
number of people
but appreciating physics thinking about
it talking about
it having a deeply seated conviction
about what is the best interpretation of
quantum mechanics
or your favorite theory of dark matter
is something that everybody can have
so thank you for following along i'm
sure you've all seen every minute of
every video
it's been a lot of fun for me it's not
the end of me talking about physics or
talking about other things so i'm not
going to go away entirely but the the
video project was a special thing
i'm very glad i did it i hope you
enjoyed it nearly as much as i did
thanks